welcome folks to the great John Watson  Clemson  I'm your mom's favorite see how much  Mike Allen is driven good thing this is  a two-minute episode let's all say what  we're thankful for ps4 yes more sane  let's see ps4 starting at 199 Holmes is  entering the race despite missing so  much time Patrick Patrick football where  head Russ as a powerup  the song Wanda's got bill Bryant no  offense  you made it harder for me to win hey put  on some Creed no I have to pee we are in  a race I think you'll get hurt think  Russ what does he air always say I'm  only gonna stay in Seattle if you dress  better  no not that the other thing automatic  supersonic hypnotic funky only two more  months of MVP race coverage  if you liked this video subscribe below  for more or we're not Jason and Jason  McCord II know you're Devon I'm pretty  sure you're Devon which one of us is  Devon you me I'll be Devon thanks Jason